MacKINNON BEST ON BEST  DRAW
NIEDERREITER PICKS UP THE THE C
SVECHNIKOV SNAPS IT.
HE WILL
MINUTES COMBINE THE 1st
PERIOD.
IT TO MARTINOOK ANDHOW HE
CREATES LOW RISK, HIGH REWARD
SPEED YOU CAN'TAHO SEALED OFF
BIG HITS IN A TURNOVER
NIEDERREITER BACK
LOOSE PUCK STILL THERRED-HOT EU
STEVE LAWRENCE ALMOST  NECAS CH
ONE TIME COLORADO AVALANCHEHE D
AND I THINK JARED BEDNAR HAS THE
CONDREY
CIRCLES SHOT WANTS TO MAKE THE
SAVE AND TH GOALTENDING FROM RA
AND LOOK HOW HIGH IS 72 POINTS
KUEMPER MAKES THE CAROLINA TRYI
BEST ARE PLAYING IN THE NHL. NO
NIEDERREITER.
THEY ARE AGAIN, 12 SECONDS IN
THE POWER-PLAY.
LAST HUNTING
SHOTOTTA SHOOTS UP FOR
LANDESKOG REBOUND RAANTA FORFFI
THE MAN
ADVANTAGE COLORADO WORKED3
MINUTES REMAINING IN TROCHECK G
AHO DEFENSE ROLES IT TO KUEMPER
AND HAS TO MAKE US SAVE.
FORTY-FIVE SECONDS
WHEN KUEMPER, NO WAY HE COULD G
SNAP THE SHOT, KUEMPER KICKS IT
>> THAT T
GOT A GOOD BOUNCE AS WELL.
>>Mike: BY
RAANTA.
FAST TREND
NOW COLORADO TRYING TO WORK THE
WAY OUT IN NEEDED THE HELP
OF THE POST, HE IS REALLY
MOVING WHILE SIDE TOPLAYERS AS
THERE IS A CHANCESHOTS
PREVIOUS ONE.
MacKINNON N
GOT KING KONG OFF HIS BACK.
HURRICANES LIVE THE PREGAME
SHOW YOU JUSTREBOUND ATTEMPT.
GOOD 2nd
REBOUND COMES FREE MacKINNON
GE
EAKIN
THIS IS ALL 2-0 CAROLINA.
ICE
AND AFTER ALL WHO HAD